Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello, welcome to The Rest is History. Now, at the end of January, we did an episode on the fascinating topic of Babylon, covering the best-known period in the city's history from the great king Nebuchadnezzar onwards. And lots of people really seemed to enjoy it. And as it's got such a fascinating and impossibly old prehistory, Tom, we said that we would have to revisit the earlier period
感谢您收听《一切皆历史》。想要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告内容、抢先体验各系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。大家好，欢迎收听《一切皆历史》。在一月底的时候，我们做了一期关于巴比伦这一迷人主题的节目，涵盖了该城市历史上最知名的时期，即从伟大的国王尼布甲尼撒二世及以后。许多人似乎真的很喜欢它。而且由于它有着如此迷人且古老到不可思议的史前史，汤姆，我们说过我们不得不重新审视早期阶段
to do it justice. Yes, we did. And we are men of our word, are we not? We always are. So we stand at the gates of the Esagila, ready to dive into the roots of ancient Babylon. If you want to know what we're talking about, go and have a look at the old podcast on Babylon and the Age
来还它一个公道。是的，我们说过。我们是言出必行的人，对吧？我们向来如此。因此，我们站在埃萨吉拉神庙的大门前，准备深入探索古巴比伦的根源。如果你想知道我们在谈论什么，去看看那期关于巴比伦和尼布甲尼撒时代的旧播客吧。
of Nebuchadnezzar. But let us now go into the gates and let's start in the most basic possible way. We had a question from somebody called First Captain. And First Captain said, basically, what was Babylon? When was it founded? Who lived there? And who ruled it? I mean, obviously, well, that's been quite a long time. Yeah. But in the very, very broadest terms, what are we talking about, Tom? Well, there's another question as well that I think goes well with that from Eric Ware. How did Babylon, a relative latecomer, make itself into the cultural epicentre of ancient Mesopotamia to the extent of even giving its own name to the whole region, i.e. Babylonia? Which kind of focuses again on this idea that Babylon, although to us it seems seems incredibly ancient actually is relatively speaking a latecomer so it's founded shortly after 2000 bc it seems to have been in a modern day iraq in what is modern day iraq uh on the the banks of the euphrates
但现在让我们走进大门，以最基础的方式开始。我们收到了一个署名“第一队长”的听众的提问。“第一队长”基本上是问：巴比伦是什么？它是什么时候建立的？谁住在那里？谁统治它？我的意思是，显然，好吧，那已经是很久以前的事了。是的。但在最最宏观的层面上，我们在谈论什么呢，汤姆？嗯，还有一个问题我也觉得和埃里克·韦尔提出的这个问题很契合：作为一个相对的后起之秀，巴比伦是如何把自己打造成古代美索不达米亚的文化中心，甚至以自己的名字来命名整个地区，即巴比伦尼亚的？这再次聚焦于这样一个观点：尽管对我们来说巴比伦看起来极其古老，但实际上相对而言它是一个后起之秀，所以它大约在公元前2000年之后不久建立，似乎位于现代伊拉克境内，也就是今天的伊拉克境内，在幼发拉底河的河岸上
um and you have these two great rivers euphrates and and the Tigris. So hence the Greek word for it, Mesopotamia, between the rivers. And these rivers, as with Egypt and the Nile, it's the rivers that give birth to urban civilization. And the first great cities in Mesopotamia are 2,000 years before the founding of Babylon. So around 4,000 BC. So 4,000, yeah. Yeah. So it's kind of one of those kind of you know people always say we are closer to cleopatra than cleopatra was to the building the pyramids and it
嗯，这里有两条大河，幼发拉底河和底格里斯河。因此，希腊语中称其为美索不达米亚，意为“两河之间”。这些河流，正如埃及与尼罗河一样，是孕育城市文明的摇篮。美索不达米亚最早的伟大城市比巴比伦的建立早了2000年。也就是公元前4000年左右。所以是4000年，是的。对。所以这就像那种人们常说的话，我们距离克利奥帕特拉的时间，比克利奥帕特拉距离建造金字塔的时间还要近，这
kind of makes your head swim yeah in a similar way you know we babylon was we are as close to the final kind of end of babylon as as a great urban centre, as the Babylonians in their earliest days were to the beginnings of urban civilisation. So we're talking about incredible, incredible depths of time. So yes, looking at recorded history, Babylon is in the midpoint. In a way, in a way. Yes, it's the Middle Ages. I mean, you know, in terms of Iraqi history and Middle Eastern history, yeah, Babylon is kind of the Middle Age. I mean, it's a kind of incredible thought. And the Babylonians have a sense of time.
让人有点头晕目眩。是的，同样的道理，你知道的，巴比伦作为伟大城市走向终结的时刻，与我们今日的距离，就如同巴比伦人在其早期接触城市文明初期的距离一样。所以我们在谈论的是难以置信、难以置信的时间深度。所以是的，从有记载的历史来看，巴比伦处于中点。某种程度上，某种程度上。是的，它是中世纪。我的意思是，就伊拉克历史和中东历史而言，是的，巴比伦有点像中世纪。我的意思是，这是一个不可思议的想法。巴比伦人有一种时间感。
They know that people have come before them and there have been civilizations before them, presumably. Well, so in a sense, they have two ways of seeing it, the kind of the mythical understanding of it that the Babylonians have arrived at by, let's say, the 6th century BC, which is the heyday of the great city that was being portrayed in my children's books, that people probably have a sense in their mind of the Ishtar Gate and the Hanging Gardens and all that kind of thing, you know, the great city of Nebuchadnezzar. So they had a sense that in a way Babylon, so the Esagila, which is the home of Marduk, who by the 6th century BC has been enshrined as the king of the gods, that this is his home. It's the first building to be built. Babylon is the first city that it's been built by some of the kind of the more junior gods as a prize for
他们知道在他们之前有人类，在他们之前也有文明，大概是这样。嗯，从某种意义上说，他们有两种看待它的方式，一种是巴比伦人在假设公元前6世纪时所形成的对它的神话理解，那是那座在我儿童读物中被描绘的伟大城市的鼎盛时期，人们脑海中可能对伊什塔尔门、空中花园以及诸如此类的事物有着某种印象，你知道的，尼布甲尼撒的伟大城市。因此，他们有一种感觉，在某种程度上巴比伦，也就是埃萨吉拉神庙，它是马尔杜克的家园，到公元前6世纪时，马尔杜克已被尊奉为众神之王，这就是他的家。它是第一座建造的建筑。巴比伦是第一座由一些较低阶的众神作为给
the greater gods um and it's part of the kind of primordial story of of of creation so so marduk in this story he there's a there's a great kind of sea serpent he's killed it he's cut it in two he's made heaven and earth out of that and then the gods gods are bored of having to do the work. And so Marduk creates humans to do the work instead of the gods. So Babylon is the first great city for humans. And that's the kind of the sacred story. And in a sense, the Esagila stands at the heart of Babylon and Babylon stands at the heart of both the universe and of time. So it's absolutely at the kind of the heart of temporal and geographical space. Okay.
伟大众神的奖赏而建造的城市，它是创世原始故事的一部分。因此，在这个故事中，马尔杜克杀了一条巨大的海蛇，他把它砍成两半，用它创造了天地，然后众神厌倦了不得不做苦工。所以马尔杜克创造了人类来替众神干活。因此，巴比伦是人类的第一座伟大城市。这就是神圣的故事。从某种意义上说，埃萨吉拉神庙矗立在巴比伦的核心，而巴比伦则矗立在宇宙和时间的核心。所以它绝对处于时间和地理空间的核心。好的。
But obviously there must be another. Yeah. I mean, it wasn't really founded by Marduk. No. So simultaneous with that, they also have a sense of the very, very distant past indeed. And this manifests itself in various ways. So right from the very, very distant past indeed. And this manifests itself in various ways. So right from the beginning,
但显然一定还有另一个。是的。我的意思是，它并不是真的由马尔杜克建立的。不。所以与此同时，他们对极其遥远的过去也有着一种感知。这以各种方式表现出来。所以从极其遥远的过去开始，这以各种方式表现出来。所以从一开始,
they seem to be looking back to a guy called Sargon who rules a city called Akkad. And we're not quite sure where Akkad was. Consensus now probably is that it was on the Tigris, but it's possible that it was actually on the Euphrates and maybe on the site of Babylon itself. But the reason that Sargon is remembered, he's this great conqueror who for the first time up until that point, Mesopotamia essentially has been an agglomeration of city-states. It's a bit like Greece will be. And Sargon conquers them all and is remembered
他们似乎在回溯一个名叫萨尔贡的人，他统治着一个叫阿卡德的城市。我们不太确定阿卡德在哪里。现在的共识可能是它在底格里斯河上，但也可能它实际上在幼发拉底河上，也许就在巴比伦本身的遗址上。萨尔贡之所以被人们铭记，是因为他是一位伟大的征服者，在此之前，美索不达米亚基本上一直是城邦的集合体。这有点像后来的希腊。萨尔贡征服了所有城邦，并被铭记
as the ruler of the first great empire. So he's the world's first emperor. Yeah. And Akkad is remembered as the kind of archetype of an imperial city. So rather than being self-sufficient, it's a city that is based on tribute and plunder. And so therefore, it's a city that is full of foreigners. It's full of exotic animals. It's cosmopolitan in a way that in due course Babylon will become as well. So it's kind of a prototype in some ways for what Babylon are ruling in the kind of same area that Sargon was ruling Akkad. And so they kind of look back to Sargon as a kind of legitimizing figure. I mean, it's a bit like, I suppose, Charlemagne perhaps looking back to Constantine or something like, you know, the line of descent is not a clear one, but it's one that the early kings of Babylon want to evoke. And this then endures right the way through.
为第一个大帝国的统治者。所以他是世界上第一位皇帝。是的。阿卡德被人们当作帝国城市的原型来铭记。因此，它不是自给自足的，而是一座建立在朝贡和掠夺基础上的城市。因此，它是一座充满外国人的城市。它充满了珍禽异兽。它具有一种大都市的风貌，假以时日，巴比伦也将如此。所以它在某些方面是萨尔贡统治同一地区时巴比伦统治事物的原型。因此，他们有点把萨尔贡看作一个具有合法化作用的人物。我的意思是，这有点像，我想，查理曼大帝回顾君士坦丁之类的人物，或者说，虽然传承线条并不清晰，但这是巴比伦早期君王想要唤起的回忆。而这一点随后一直持续下去。
So the Babylonians are obsessed with learning, with the past. There's a massive kind of antiquarian strain. And right up to the end of it, so Nabonidus, who is the last kind of native king of Babylon, he rules before the Persians conquer it. That's the end of Babylonian independence, effectively. But he's a massive antiquarian. So he goes away, and we'll probably come to why he goes away, but reports reach him
因此，巴比伦人痴迷于学问，痴迷于过去。这里有一种强烈的崇古情结。一直到最后，也就是那波尼德，他是巴比伦最后一位本土国王，在波斯人征服它之前统治。那实际上是巴比伦独立的终结。但他是一个狂热的古董爱好者。所以他离开了，我们可能会谈到他为什么离开，但有报告传到他那里
that people have dug up a statue of Sargon, of Akkad, and he comes rushing back. He's so excited, he wants to have a look at it. And he has a daughter, who's a princess, Enigaldinanna. Good pronunciation, Tom. Thank you very much. And she, it seems, so this is Leonard Woolley, the great British archaeologist, is excavating Ur, much, much older city than Babylon. And obviously, in a sense, the Babylonians kind of remember that. And she seems to have constructed a museum of antiquities at Ur. So when they were found, these are antiquities that are reaching back to the beginnings of Mesopotamian history. And the greatest thing is that they seem to have had kind of museum captions explaining what a collection of antiquities are. So right at the end of Babylonian independence, you get the sense that people are absolutely at the top.
说人们挖出了一尊阿卡德的萨尔贡的雕像，他急忙赶了回来。他太兴奋了，想去看看它。他有一个女儿，是一位公主，名叫恩尼加尔迪南娜。发音不错，汤姆。非常感谢。看起来她——这是伟大的英国考古学家伦纳德·伍利在乌尔进行发掘，乌尔是一座比巴比伦古老得多的城市。显然，在某种意义上，巴比伦人对此有所记忆。她似乎在乌尔建造了一座古物博物馆。所以当它们被发掘时，这些古物可以追溯到美索不达米亚历史的开端。最棒的是，它们似乎配有某种博物馆说明文字，解释这些古物收藏是什么。因此，在巴比伦独立的最后阶段，你会感觉到人们完全处于巅峰状态。
The royal family are at. Yeah, that's what the princess, the princess writes the captions. She seems to have done, yeah. I mean, I don't know whether she personally did, but it's her museum. Right. So it's a bit like if, you know, Princess Anne or Carrie Johnson were setting up their own museums about Athelstan, Tom. Exactly. Yes. Or kind of the Neolithic or something with stone axes or something like that. Yes, it is. And the Babylonians can do that because they are a deeply literate society.
皇室成员处于。是的，这就是公主，公主写了说明文字。她似乎确实这么做了，是的。我的意思是，我不知道是不是她亲自做的，但这是她的博物馆。没错。所以这有点像，你知道的，如果安妮公主或凯莉·约翰逊建立他们自己的关于埃塞尔斯坦的博物馆，汤姆。完全正确。是的。或者某种新石器时代的东西，带着石斧之类的东西。是的，确实如此。巴比伦人之所以能做到这一点，是因为他们是一个高度识字的社会。
Okay. deeply literate society. And so I mentioned the Greeks and the Jews. So Herodotus, the first great historian, and the writers of what Christians call the Old Testament, the Tanakh for Jews. And that is the inheritance that the people in the West have had. So that's what essentially has always determined our understanding of what Babylon looked like. But in the 19th century, archaeologists went there and they discovered all these kind of tablets with what came to be called cuneiform, and the language got cracked. And now I think that the total volume of writings by Babylonians and by Assyrians, the great power to the north, who we'll also be talking about,
好的。高度识字的社会。所以我提到了希腊人和犹太人。因此，希腊第一位伟大的历史学家希罗多德，以及基督徒所称的旧约、犹太人所称的塔纳赫的作者们。这就是西方人所继承的遗产。所以这基本上决定了我们对巴比伦样貌的理解。但在19世纪，考古学家们去到那里，他们发现了所有这些刻有后来被称为楔形文字的泥板，并且这种语言被破译了。现在我认为巴比伦人和亚述人（北方的强大势力，我们稍后也会讨论）的全部著作总量
is equivalent to the entire corpus of Latin literature. So there's tons of stuff. There is tons and tons of stuff. So we've got the Greek and the Jewish writings that are now supplemented by the writings of the Babylonians and Assyrians themselves. And so therefore, over the past, whatever, 150, 170 years, it's been possible for people
相当于拉丁文学的全部文库。所以有大量的资料。有数不尽的资料。所以我们有希腊和犹太人的著作，现在又有了巴比伦和亚述人自己的著作作为补充。因此，在过去的150年、170年左右的时间里，人们有可能
to have a much, much better sense of what the history of babylon was before the kind of the great days of nebuchadnezzar in the sixth century right the way back to to the beginnings of it okay let me take you back to the beginning tom um so you've had akkad we don't exactly know where that is that's about what is that uh 2300 years before the birth of christ um and then babylon seems to have been founded if i'm right about four centuries later in the 19th century bc or so so 1900 years before the birth of christ and the man who found it i believe is called samu abam is that is that right am i pronouncing that correctly i don't know but i always i've always thought of him as sumo abam just because it seems funnier okay fine um and uh
对公元前6世纪尼布甲尼撒伟大时代之前，一直到其起源的巴比伦历史有一个更好得多的了解。好吧，让我带你回到最初，汤姆。所以你讲了阿卡德，我们不确定它在哪里，那是大约在基督诞生前2300年左右，然后巴比伦似乎大约在四个世纪后的公元前19世纪左右建立，也就是基督诞生前1900年左右，建立它的人据我所知叫苏穆阿比姆，是这样的吗？我发音正确吗？我不知道，但我一直把它叫做苏穆阿比姆，只是因为它听起来更有趣。好吧，没问题。嗯，
now who is he and and who are the people that found it are they just local farmers or what's the story no he so he is an amurite say that again amurite so uh that's kind of um for uh more elevated listeners yeah he runs a flower stall in uh in the east end um so the amorites are um they are semitic speakers probably from syria they're they're mentioned in the bible so maybe in in canaan as well and they're the kind of classic guys who right from the beginning of time right from the beginning of civilization have kind of operated on the fringes of urban society okay so you know this is the story that that just repeats and repeats and repeats itself. And essentially, whenever they get a sense of weakness, you know, they come in. So it's the same stories you get with the Arabs,
现在他是谁？建立它的人又是谁？他们只是当地农民还是怎么回事？不，他是阿摩利人。再说一遍，阿摩利人。所以，这有点像，对更有品味的听众来说，是的，他在东区的花坛里摆摊。所以阿摩利人是操闪米特语的人，可能来自叙利亚，他们在圣经中被提及，所以可能也在迦南，他们是一群从时间之初、文明之初就一直在城市社会边缘活动的人。好吧，你知道，这是一个不断重复、重复、再重复的故事。基本上，每当他们觉察到虚弱时，他们就会入侵。所以这和你在7世纪与阿拉伯人
you know, in the 7th century. And the Amorites come in and they either take over what had been a kind of village or a small town or they found it or whatever, but they establish a city and they establish a monarchy because it's pretty fundamental to the way that the Mesopotamians see the world that you have to have a king. Is the king a representative of the gods
身上得到的故事是一样的。阿摩利人涌入，他们要么接管了一个原本是村庄或小镇的地方，要么建立了它，诸如此类，但他们建立了一个城市，并建立了一个君主制，因为对美索不达米亚人理解世界的方式来说，拥有一个国王是相当根本的。国王是众神的代表
or the king is embodiment of some divine order or what? He's the kind of interface between humans and gods and he's the guy who can be guaranteed to protect his subjects from war to give them justice to ensure that the correct rituals are carried out so that the gods won't get cross um and you you have all this say what's called wisdom literature it's um kind of pithy sentiments that people are encouraged to recommend to to bear in mind and again and again you get these kind of ideas that um so there's this this this one that it's kind of written about 2500 bc you should submit to the strong man you should humble
还是某种神圣秩序的化身？他是人类与神明之间的某种交汇点，他是那个能够确保保护其子民免受战争之苦、给予他们公正、确保正确仪式得以执行以使神明不会生气的人。你会看到所有这些被称为智慧文学的东西，它们是鼓励人们铭记的精辟格言。你会一次又一次地看到这些观点，比如有一篇大约写于公元前2500年的文章：你应该顺从强者，你应该在
yourself before the man who wields power so it's very kind of putin friendly right yeah you know there's the idea is is that that there's a big man and you should basically do what he says thomas hobbes yeah yeah and and then hopefully he will then look after you and give you justice yes if you're poor but but obedience is there so so so babylon is a city that is also a monarchy and samu abom is the the king? He's the first one that we know of. And here's a crucial question that's going to run through this podcast. How do we know about him? We know about it through these cuneiform tablets.
掌权者面前保持谦卑。所以这非常符合普京的胃口，对吧？是的，你知道，这里的观点是，有一个大人物，你基本上应该听他的话，托马斯·霍布斯。是的，然后希望他会照顾你并给予你公正。是的，如果你很穷的话。但服从是存在的。所以，巴比伦也是一个君主制城市，苏穆阿比姆是国王？他是我们所知的第一个国王。这里有一个贯穿本期播客的关键问题：我们是如何了解他的？我们通过这些楔形文献了解他。
We know there are kind of king lists, as you get in Egypt. So there is this vast kind of corpus of material that scholars are working their way through right now. I mean, you know, there's loads and loads that haven't been read. And this is the 19th century BC. And do we have any sense, Tom, of what that city... Well, first, I mean, I know this is in many ways an impossible question. So is it on the banks of the river?
我们知道这里有类似于埃及那种国王世系表。所以学者们现在正在研究这庞大的资料库。我的意思是，有大量的大量的资料还没有被阅读过。这是公元前19世纪。汤姆，我们对那座城市的样貌有什么概念吗……首先，我的意思是，我知道这在很多方面是一个不可能的问题。所以它是在河岸上吗？
Of the Euphrates. Of the Euphrates. We're talking about it as a city. But at this stage, presumably, it's what we would now see as a town, right? I mean, it's not. It's really difficult to know because there's almost no trace of it. I mean, actually, there's literally no trace of it. Because I think there was several people asked, you know, what is left of Babylon?
幼发拉底河。幼发拉底河。我们把它当成一座城市来谈论。但在现阶段，大概它就是我们现在所理解的一个城镇，对吧？我的意思是，它不是。这真的很难以置信，因为几乎没有留下任何痕迹。我的意思是，事实上，字面意义上没有任何痕迹。因为我想有好几个人问过，巴比伦还剩下什么？
One of the problems with this, say, unlike egypt where you have things built of stone there isn't really any stone available so stone is a very very precious commodity in mesopotamia so instead they make things out of baked mud bricks right so hence my magnificent opening in persian fire everything is made of mud that's how so all these kind of great monuments the ishtar gate everything is made out of baked mud that are baked really, really hard. But the problem with them is that they kind of melt away. So you have this thing over the course of Mesopotamian history. So the great ziggurats, which are the kind of stepped, great stepped temples, they kind of melt away like kind of chocolate cakes left in the rain.
这里的问题之一，与埃及不同，埃及有石头建造的东西，而美索不达米亚没有真正可用的石头，所以在美索不达米亚石头是非常非常珍贵的商品。因此，他们用烤过的泥砖来建造东西。所以正如我在《波斯之火》中那宏伟的开篇所说，一切都是用泥土建造的。这就是所有这些宏伟的纪念碑，伊什塔尔门，一切都是用经过烘烤的泥土制成的，烤得非常非常坚硬。但它们的问题在于它们会融化消失。所以在美索不达米亚的历史进程中，你会发现这种情况。所以巨大的高塔神庙，也就是那些阶梯状的巨大阶梯神庙，它们就像留在雨中的巧克力蛋糕一样融化了。
And so then what people do is they just kind of build over the top of them. And again and again, you get the sense that cities rise up, they collapse, and they get rebuilt. So the Esagila, for instance, I mean, that does seem to be properly ancient. That does seem to have this shrine that becomes the Great Shrine of Marduk. That does seem to originate in the beginnings of Babylon, which is why it's commemorated as the oldest building not just in babylon but in the world in due course but it's um it gets destroyed i mean we know it gets destroyed yeah and then they rebuild it so in what sense is it but does that do they have a sense tom from the very beginning that uh life human history time is a saga of kind of, it's a cycle of destruction and rebirth?
所以人们所做的就是直接在它们的废墟上建造。你会一次又一次地感觉到，城市拔地而起，坍塌，然后又被重建。例如，埃萨吉拉神庙，我的意思是，这看起来确实非常古老。它似乎确实拥有这座成为马尔杜克伟大神庙的神龛。这似乎起源于巴比伦的初创时期，这就是为什么它不仅被纪念为巴比伦最古老的建筑，而且在后来的发展中也被视为世界上最古老的建筑，但它被摧毁了。我的意思是，我们知道它被摧毁了。是的，然后他们重建了它。那么从什么意义上说，汤姆，他们从一开始就有一种感觉，即人类历史、时间是一个……的传奇？它是一个毁灭与重生的循环吗？
Is that built into the world? I think they have a cyclical sense of time. But they also have a sense that everything can kind of... So Babylon becomes famous as a city of sorcerers, of astronomers, of astrologers. And the idea that the past and the future are written in the heavens and that therefore what is happening on the earthly stage of Babylon is reflecting and reflective of what is happening in the heavens is also a crucial part of the way that the Babylonians understand themselves. So they feel that the city is not just a city. You know, it's not kind of the equivalent of Basingstoke. This is, it's sacred.
这融入了他们的世界观吗？我认为他们有一种时间的循环观念。但他们也有一种观念，即万物皆可……因此，巴比伦作为一座巫师、天文学家和占星家之城而闻名。过去和未来都写在星空中，因此巴比伦大地上发生的事情，既反映了天空中发生的事情，也是其折射，这也是巴比伦人自我理解的关键部分。所以他们觉得这座城不仅仅是一座城。你知道，它不相当于贝辛斯托克（Basingstoke）。这是神圣的。
It's at the center of things. And it's that that animates the Babylonians. And over the course of their 2,000 years of history, other people come to accept that. And so the story of how that happens is also really, really interesting. And it's first tied up with one of the heirs of Sumo Obama, who I prefer to call him, the famous Hammurabi. Well, just a quick note.
它处于万物的中心。正是这一点激发了巴比伦人的活力。在他们两千年的历史进程中，其他人也开始接受这一点。因此，这一切发生的故事也非常非常有趣。它首先与苏木·拉贝尔（Sumu-la-El）的一个继承人联系在一起，我更愿意叫他著名的汉谟拉比。好吧，顺便提一下。
If you are from Basingstoke and you do think your city has a divine significance, I apologize. Write in, let us know. But yeah, but Tom, so Hammurabi or whatever you, what did you call him? Hammurabi. Hammurabi. I think the diversity of pronunciations
如果你来自贝辛斯托克，并且确实认为你们的城市具有神圣的意义，我深表歉意。写信告诉我们吧。但是，汤姆，汉谟拉比或者随便你叫他什么——你刚才叫他什么？汉谟拉比。汉谟拉比。我认为发音的多样性
is one of the great joys of this podcast. Strengths of this podcast. So we've moved on 100 years or so from the, 200 years maybe from the foundation of the city, I guess. Yeah. And now it's becoming under Hammurabi or whatever you want to call him. Am I right in thinking it's becoming more of an imperial power
是这个播客的一大乐趣。也是这个播客的优势。所以，距离这座城市的建立，我们已经前进了大约100年，也许200年，我猜。是的。现在，在汉谟拉比或随便你怎么称呼他的统治下，它正变得越来越像一个帝国强权，
taking over other towns, cities nearby? So this is where the kind of comparison with Sargon comes in is that Hammurabi is a great conqueror. He buys his time and then he seems to have basically just kind of gone berserk. And he conquers this great empire that basically embraces most of certainly southern Mesopotamia, reaching up in towards Syria. And, you know, so he's a great conqueror. But the other reason that he's remembered is that he's a great lawgiver.
接管周围的其他城镇和城市？所以，这里与萨尔贡（Sargon）的对比就显现出来了：汉谟拉比是一位伟大的征服者。他养精蓄锐，然后似乎彻底疯狂了。他征服了这个伟大的帝国，基本上囊括了美索不达米亚南部的绝大部分，一直延伸到叙利亚。所以，他是一位伟大的征服者。但他被人们铭记的另一个原因是他是一位伟大的立法者。
Well, there's the code, isn't there? And this is one of the foundational documents in some ways of, well, it's one of the first great documents of human history, isn't there and this is one of the foundational documents in some ways of well it's one of the first great documents of human history isn't it is if you were doing a sort of compilation of top documents this is this is often number one or two in the list it is although whether it's a law code in the way that we would understand it is much debated um you know and this is kind of part of the fascination and the frustration of ancient history is that you get a great chunk of writing and you don't have the context that necessarily enables you to work out quite how do you frame it. law uh or it could be um a collection of royal rulings um or it could be a kind of an accounting from the king to the gods of everything that he's done and what sort of things are in it well it's written very kind of poetically yeah so just to reiterate it's not the kind of thing that you would get you know kind of bill of parliament or anything like that um it features a lot of boasting from the king um so the king i stand head and shoulders above
好吧，这里有法典，不是吗？从某些方面来看，这是人类历史上的奠基文献之一，好吧，这是人类历史上的第一批伟大文献之一，不是吗？从某些方面来看，这是人类历史上的奠基文献之一，好吧，这是人类历史上的第一批伟大文献之一，不是吗？如果你要编纂一份顶级文献列表，这通常是列表中的第一或第二位。确实如此，尽管它是否是我们所理解的那种法典，仍有很大争议。嗯，你知道，这也是古代历史令人着迷又沮丧的一部分，你得到了大量文字，却未必拥有能让你弄清楚如何去框定它的上下文。法律，或者它可能是国王对神的统治裁决的汇编；或者它可能是国王对神灵做过的一切事情的账目。里面都有什么内容呢？嗯，它的写法非常具有诗意。是的，所以重申一下，这并不是你会得到的那种议会法案之类东西；嗯，它包含了很多来自国王的吹嘘。所以国王说，我高居于其他国王之上，我的言辞基本上是辉煌的，在勤奋方面我绝对没有对手。所以有很多那种东西。那是你在跟他谈论这件事。一点也没有，多米尼克，一点也没有。有很多关于婚姻的内容。没错。有很多关于继承的内容。这里有一种感觉，即国王正在维护法律和框架。他在某种程度上使人们社会化。没错，有一些人们应该遵循的固定规则，而他正在将其实施（你知道的，他在发表它们），这些都有助于实现神灵所理解的正义事业。我的意思是，这
other kings um my words are basically brilliant um i'm absolutely i have no rival in terms of my diligence so there's a lot of that kind of stuff. That's you talking to him about it. Not at all, Dominic, not at all. There's a lot of stuff about marriages. Right. There's a lot of stuff about inheritance. There's a sense that the king is upholding the laws and the frameworks. And he's kind of socializing people. Right. there are there are set rules that people should follow and he is he is kind of in trying you know he's delivering them and that these serve the causes of justice as understood by the gods i mean that's
基本上就是这样。我认为，我们在某种程度上有一种倾向，想把它等同于我们对法律的理解，我认为这大概应该受到抵制，因为它总是更加古怪、奇异和遥远。很有道理。那么汉谟拉比本人呢，汤姆？因为利亚姆·博伊德（Liam Boyd）有一个问题。他说，汉谟拉比是一位可以被视为历史伟人的领袖吗？他在军事和行政上都取得了成功，并改变了美索不达米亚的宗教和政治景观？所以我们整个系列的第一期播客就是关于“伟大”的。汉谟拉比，他是那种被视为泰坦式、真正具有泰坦般气魄的人物吗？还是说这只是因为我们拥有的那些对他评价正面的史料而造成的一种偶然？他把自己看作一个泰坦式的人物。他非常明确地把自己视为萨尔贡的继承人，而萨尔贡正是伟人的原型。
basically what it is and i think that um but there's a kind of there's a there's a temptation on our behalf to kind of identify it with the understanding of law that we have that I think should probably be resisted because it's always kind of, it's weirder and stranger and more distant than that. Fair enough. What about Hammurabi himself, Tom? Because Liam Boyd had a question. He said, is Hammurabi a leader who could be considered a great man of history, successful both militarily, administratively and changed the religious and political landscape of Mesopotamia? So our very first podcast of this entire series was about greatness. Is Hammurabi, is he one of these people who is seen as a sort of a titanic, a genuinely titanic figure? Or is that just an accident because of the sources we have that reflect well on him? He sees himself as a titanic figure. He sees himself pretty clearly as the heir of Sargon, who's the archetype of a great man.
美索不达米亚绝对是一个信仰伟人的社会。我的意思是，信仰伟大的国王。所以绝对以这个标准来看，他是一位伟大的征服者，也是一位伟大的立法者。你知道，按我们的标准也是如此。我的意思是，这是一种拿破仑式的记录。但就像拿破仑一样，他的帝国随后崩溃了。
And Mesopotamia is absolutely a society that believes in great men. I mean, great kings. So absolutely by that standard, he's a great conqueror and he's a great lawgiver. You know, and by our standards as well. I mean, that's a kind of Napoleonic record. But rather like Napoleon, his empire. Then crumbles.
它崩溃了。基本上在他死后，帝国就崩溃了。是的，差不多。是的，差不多。是的，差不多。所以你认为他的帝国在很大程度上是一个个人的创造，而不是一种制度上的创造？嗯，我认为在这一点上，就像萨尔贡所做的那样，汉谟拉比征服的是那些认为自己天生独立的城邦。
It crumbles. And it crumbles when he dies, basically, after he dies. Yeah, pretty much. Yeah, pretty much. Yeah, pretty much. So it's very much a personal creation rather than a kind of institutional one, his empire, do you think? Well, I think at this point, so as Sargon had done, Hammurabi is conquering city-states that regard themselves as being naturally independent.
没错。所以这有点像马其顿人征服希腊城邦，城邦并不喜欢这样。他们不断试图摆脱这种枷锁。从本质上讲，在汉谟拉比的一生之后，巴比伦又退回到了贝辛斯托克的地位。你知道，你真的是跟贝辛斯托克或雷丁（Reading）之类的地方杠上了。我的意思是，这是一个富裕、繁荣、略带外省色彩的地方，它曾有过属于自己的高光时刻，但现在又退缩了回去。而且，你知道，有好几个世纪，你根本不知道那里发生了什么。好吧，它成了受害者，对吧？我的意思是，它遭到了赫梯人（Hittites）的攻击，赫梯人是另一个神秘的民族，对吧？来自安纳托利亚。
Right. So again, it's a bit like the Macedonians conquering the city-states of Greece, that the city-states don't like it. They're kind of constantly trying to throw off, you know, the yoke. And essentially after Hammurabi's life Babylon reverts back to being Basingstoke you know you've got really got it in for Basingstoke or Reading or whatever I mean it's it's it's it's a kind of you know it's a wealthy prosperous slightly provincial place with that has had its moment in the sun but now has kind of retreated again um and you know for several centuries you don't really know what's going on well it's on the receiving end right i mean it gets uh attacked by the hittites who are another sort of mysterious people aren't they anatolian
赫梯人，我想是的。所以，来自现在的土耳其，他们建立了一个庞大的帝国。赫梯人做了一件事，我认为这会成为一个常见的主题。他们偷走或没收了马尔杜克（Marduk）的神像。这到底是怎么回事？告诉我，向我解释一下关于马尔杜克神像的事情，以及为什么人们基本上一直在偷它。但在你回答之前，汤姆，等等。我们要休息一下。
the hittites i think are they yes so so from what's now turkey and they establish a kind of a massive empire um and the hittites do something that, and they establish a kind of a massive empire. And the Hittites do something that I think will become a bit of a theme. So they steal or confiscate a statue of Marduk. Now, what's all that about? Tell me, explain to me about the statue of Marduk and why basically people keep stealing it. But before you answer that, actually, Tom, hold on. We will take a break.
我们要去欣赏我们自己的马尔杜克神像，几分钟后就会回来。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde），我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman），我们共同主持《一切皆娱乐》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝八卦的好去处，在我们的问答环节中，我们会拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想收听无广告节目、获取独家播客以及提前购买现场演出门票，请访问therestisentertainment.com。也就是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的沉淀》（The Rest Is History）。现在，汤姆，你刚才正要解释他们为什么一直偷马尔杜克的神像。所以正如我们所提到的，马尔杜克被供奉在埃萨吉拉神庙（Esagila）中。根据传说，是他自己建造了埃萨吉拉神庙。显然，那并没有发生。
We'll go and admire our own statues of Marduk, and we'll be back in just a few minutes i'm marina hyde and i'm richard osmond and together we host the rest is entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our q a we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to the resterestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. Now, Tom, you were about to explain why they keep stealing the statue of Marduk. So Marduk, as we've mentioned, is enshrined in the Esagila. According to legend, he builds the Esagila himself. Obviously, that didn't happen.
他建造了自己的雕像。我的意思是，他确实试图字面意义上地和他的妻子住在那里。字面意义上，所以这不是象征性的？不，他字面意义上就住在那里。他和他的妻子住在那里。所以那里也有他妻子的雕像。他们的儿子在镇外有一所房子，每年都会被接进来。所以这有点像他刚从大学放假回来或者别的什么。
And he constructs his own statue. I mean, he sought literally to live there with his wife. Literally, so it's not symbolic. No, he literally lives there. He lives there with his wife. So there's a statue of her as well. Their son, who has a house outside town every year, is brought in. So he's kind of like he's coming back from university or something.
把所有的脏衣服都带上。把所有的脏衣服都带上。马尔杜克可以说是巴比伦的保护神，但在这一点上，他其实也就是个保护神而已。因此，他有点像巴比伦的象征，但在这一点上，他真的也就是个象征而已。因此，他有点像巴比伦的象征。所以如果你征服了巴比伦并偷走了马尔杜克，你就等于移除了它的伟大保护神。因此，正如你所说，这是一个贯穿历史的节点，因为每次巴比伦被攻陷，做这件事的人都会顺走马尔杜克的神像。所以有个简单的问题，汤姆，打断一下。当这些人偷走神像时——也许这个问题的答案无从知晓——他们认为自己是在字面意义上偷走神明，
Bring all his washing with him. Bring all his washing with him. Marduk is kind of the patron of Babylon, but he's nothing really more than that at this point. But therefore, he's kind of like the symbol of Babylon, but he's nothing really more than that at this point. But therefore, he's kind of like the symbol of Babylon. So if you conquer Babylon and you steal Marduk, you're removing its great patron. And therefore, as you say, this is something that punctuates the history, because every time Babylon gets captured, the people who've done it nick the statue of Marduk. So a quick question, Tom, just to interrupt. So when these people steal the statue, maybe the answer to this is unknowable. Do they think they are literally stealing the god,
还是仅仅在偷一个神明的象征？我认为很难从赫梯人身上了解这一点，因为他们来自一个文化上非常不同的社会。但我觉得，当你有——比如说亚述人（Assyrians），他们后来成为了巴比伦人的死敌，他们有着相同的文化背景。亚述人把巴比伦视为世界的伟大文化中心，他们基本上是按巴比伦对自己的估价来看待巴比伦的。是的。所以，当他们偷走马尔杜克的神像时，是的，绝对地，他们觉得自己带走了神明，而且他们对此感到紧张，因为他们觉得这可能会触犯神圣。但我认为赫梯人不这么认为。
or are they merely stealing a symbol of the god? I think it's hard to know with the Hittites, because they're from a culturally a very different society. But I think when you have, so in due course, say the Assyrians, who become the great rivals of the Babylonians, that they're bred of the same cultural matrix. And the Assyrians look to Babylon as, you know, the great cultural center of the world, they kind of take Babylon at its own estimation. Yeah. And so therefore, when they steal the statue of Marduk, yes, absolutely, they feel that they're taking the God, and they're nervous about it, because they steal the statue of Marduk, yes, absolutely. They feel that they're taking the God and they're nervous about it because they feel that they're potentially committing sacrilege. But I think the Hittites don't think that.
我的意思是，对赫梯人来说，这有点像罗马人在洗劫耶路撒冷时偷走圣殿的宝藏。这是一种羞辱被征服者、将他们的鼻子按在失败灰烬中的方式。因此，巴比伦在经历这一切后，感到内心受到创伤。在此之后，他们被一个被称为加喜特人（Kassites）的神秘民族所接管。他们是谁？这是，
I mean, the Hittites, it's kind of like the Romans stealing the treasures of the temple when they sacked Jerusalem. It's a way to humiliate and rub the noses of the conquered in the ashes of their defeat. And so Babylon is left kind of traumatized by that. And so they get taken over by, after that, by a mysterious people called the Kassites. And who are they? This is,
坦白说。这是我第一次听说加喜特人。他们是谁？他们非常不为人知。他们说一种有点像巴斯克语的语言。它似乎不是闪米特语。它似乎，
I'll be frank. This is the first I've ever heard of the Kassites. Who are they? They're very obscure. They speak a language that is kind of a bit like Basque. It doesn't seem to be Semitic. It doesn't seem to, you know,
它与所使用的任何语言都没有任何关系。他们大概不打回力球（pilota），也不以自己的平托斯小吃（pinchos）为傲。嗯，所以，并没有。但他们最终变得非常非常巴比伦化。所以他们变得比巴比伦人还要巴比伦。他们成为了巴比伦人历史中一切事物的伟大赞助者。所以这是一个非常典型的征服者被同化并接受被征服者文化的例子，基本上是这样的。是的，所以又一次，这就像查理曼大帝资助僧侣抄写拉丁经典一样。
it doesn't bear any relationship to any of the kind of languages that are being spoken. They don't play pilota and pride themselves on their pinchos, presumably. Well, so, no. But they end up becoming very, very Babylonian. So they become more Babylonlonian than the babylonians they they become great great patrons of you know everything that ties the babylonians into their history um so this is a very example of the invader who is assimilated and takes on the the the the culture of the conquered people basically yeah so so again's, it's Charlemagne sponsoring monks writing out the Latin classics.
是的。完全是这样。而且，他们统治了巴比伦大约400年。这就是那个时期。所以我们之前谈到了阿肯那顿（Akhenaten），在我们制作的关于图坦卡蒙（Tutankhamen）的那期节目中谈到了那个时期。阿肯那顿是四大超级大国之一的统治者。所以包括我们提到的赫梯人、埃及本身（当然），还有被称为米坦尼（Mitanni）的人（他们是美索不达米亚和赫梯人之间的缓冲王国），然后是巴比伦。所以阿肯那顿——我们从他的首都阿马尔纳（Amarna）发现了所有这些泥板，在这些泥板中，阿肯那顿写信给各种外国国王。
Yeah. That's exactly what it is. And they, they rule Babylon for about 400 years. And this is the period. So we took, we had, we talked about Akhenaten in the episode we did about Tutankhamen in that period. And Akhenaten is one of the ruler of four superpowers. So the Hittites, who we've mentioned, Egypt itself, of course, people called the Mitanni, who are the kind of buffer kingdom between Mesopotamia and the Hittites, and then Babylon. And so Akhenaten, so we have all these kind of tablets from his capital, Amarna, in which Akhenaten is writing to kind of various foreign kings.
而巴比伦，巴比伦国王是他在信中称为“兄弟”的其他三位国王之一。如果这是一个小王国，他大概不会这么做吧？小王国大概不会吧，是的。阿肯那顿的父亲阿蒙霍特普三世（Amenhotep III），也就是太阳王——任何去过大英博物馆的人都见过那个带着神秘微笑的伟大肖像半身像，那就是阿蒙霍特普三世。他娶了巴比伦国王的女儿。所以，近东的超级大国之间存在着这样一张网络，而巴比伦，巴比伦也位列其中。打断一下，我喜欢这个主题的一点是加喜特人。加喜特人只是巴比伦历史上的一个小插曲，但他们统治了400年。我的意思是，他们的统治时间是美国存在时间的两倍。是的，我想我们花了几个小时讨论杰米·索普（Jeremy Thorpe）丑闻，然后我们就把加喜特人打发了，
And Babylon, the king of Babylon, is one of the three other kings that he describes as brother. Which he wouldn't do if it was a minor kingdom, presumably. kingdom presumably yeah and his and akhenaten's dad uh aminotep the third this kind of the sun king uh anyone who's been to the british museum seen that great kind of portrait bust with the enigmatic smile that's aminotep the third and he marries a daughter of the king of babylon so um there's this kind of network of you know the superpowers of the near east uh and babylon babylon is up there what i love about doing this subject just to interrupt is the cassites so the cassites are just an episode of babylon in history but but they rule 400 years i mean they ruled for twice as long as the united states has existed yeah i think we spend hours going through the jeremy thorpe scandal and then we just dismiss the
你知道，我知道他们只在那里待了400年。我懂。我懂。重要的事情正在发生，因为正是在加喜特人的统治下，你开始有一种感觉。所以，回到埃里克·韦尔（Eric Ware）的问题，它最终是如何将自己的名字赋予整个地区的？正是在加喜特人统治时期，这个过程发生了，这些独立城邦的聚合开始被吸纳进一个被称为“巴比伦尼亚”（Babylonia）的实体中。在这个阶段，汤姆，我们对作为地点的巴比伦有什么概念吗？那里有多少人居住？它看起来是什么样的？或者泥土再次融化了？泥土融化了，你知道，有一些泥板上面有图画、插图，但它们是象征性的。因此，很难知道它们到底有多高的可信度。
cassites and you know i know they're only there for 400 years. I know. I know. And important things are happening because it's under the Kassites that you start to get a sense. So again, to go back to Eric Ware's question, how did it end up giving its name to the whole region? It's under the Kassites that this process happens, that this agglomeration of independent city-states start to be absorbed into something that that is called babylonia and at this stage tom do we have any sense of babylon the place how many people live there what it looks like or again is as the mud is melted the mud is melted there you know there are kind of um so there are uh clay tablets on which there are drawings, illustrations, but they're symbolic. And so it's difficult to know exactly how credibly they should be taken.
我认为要了解这座城市是什么样子非常非常困难。但它是一座伟大的首都。它是一座伟大的首都，嗯，它是一座伟大的首都。它显然具有伟大首都应有的建筑体量，因为，我们之所以知道这一点，是因为在公元前1250年，亚述人进入了法姆。他们是现在我们所说更靠北的伊拉克人，亚述人。是的，没错。所以那是摩苏尔、库尔德斯坦那种地区。他们的首都位于阿瑟（Assur），他们的首都位于阿瑟。但你认为，当伊斯兰国蜂拥而至并占领它时，他们以摧毁亚述雕像和城市等而闻名。所以，是的，基本上就是伊拉克北部。而亚述人我认为是所有古代帝国中最可怕的。
I think it's very, very difficult to get a sense of what the city's like. But it's a great capital. It's a great capital uh it's a great capital it it it clearly has the kind of architectural heft that a great capital should have because um we we know this because um at 12 50 the assyrians enter the enter the the farm and they are they are what we would now call more northern iraq assyrian yeah right yeah so that's up mosul kurdistan that kind of area their capital is asser their capital is asser but you think so when the islamic states swept in and occupied it they they were notorious for kind of destroying assyrian statues and and cities and so on um so yeah so so northern iraq basically um and the assyrians are i think the most terrifying of all the ancient empires
我的意思是，把他们当作邻居，就像旁边有一只愤怒的大黄蜂。因为基本上他们对待帝国主义的方法是相当残酷的，有很多斩首、刺穿、毁灭和人民的迁徙。亚述帝国的后期表现尤为如此，但即使在早期，把他们当作邻居也不是件好玩的事。所以当亚述人攻击巴比伦时，有点像他们在攻击母亲。你知道，他们认为这是一个非常重要的
i i mean having them as a neighbor it's it's like having a kind of angry hornet next to you because basically their approach to imperialism is to it's it's quite brutal there's quite a lot of beheadings and impalings and destruction and transplantation of peoples um this is particularly true of the kind of the later uh manifestation of the assyrian empire but even the early one they're they're they're not fun to have as your neighbors so when the asssyrians attack Babylon, it's kind of like they're attacking mummy. You know, they see it as a very important,
地方。
very significant city to which they owe a lot. But that doesn't in any way stop them from absolutely pulverising it. So it's the vandals sacking Rome, let's say, or something like that, is it? Is that maybe the analogy? I think they're more like Macedon to classical Greece, perhaps. It's that kind of relationship. They're seen by the Babylonians as northern brutes and barbarians. The Assyrians see themselves as having a kind of commonality with the Babylonians,
一座非常重要的城市，他们欠这座城市很多。但这并没有阻止他们将其彻底毁灭。所以，这就像是汪达尔人洗劫罗马，对吧，或者是类似的事情？这或许就是那个类比吗？我想他们可能更像是马其顿之于古典希腊。这就是那种关系。在巴比伦人看来，他们是北方的粗人和蛮族。亚述人则认为自己与巴比伦人有某种共同性，
but at the same time, they're slightly chippy, like throw their weight around. And so the Assyrians attack Babylon. You get this great thing from the Assyrian king saying, I captured the king of Babylon. I trod with my foot upon his lordly neck as though it were a footstool. And inevitably, they steal the statue of Marduk. Of course they do. But they don't hold onto it, do they? Don't they give it back? They do, because they're worried that they've committed sacrilege by removing it. Right, so they go to all the efforts of taking it up, presumably in a great ceremonial hullabaloo,
但与此同时，他们又有点自大，喜欢耀武扬威。于是亚述人进攻巴比伦。你从亚述国王那里听到了这个伟大的声明：我俘虏了巴比伦国王，我用脚踩着他高傲的颈项，就像踩着一个脚凳。不可避免地，他们偷走了马尔杜克的雕像。他们当然会这么做。但他们并没有一直占有着它，对吧？难道他们没有把它还回去吗？他们还了，因为他们担心通过移走它而犯下了亵渎神明的罪。没错，所以他们费尽周折把它请回去，想必是在一场盛大的仪式喧闹中，
and then they sneak it back or take it back, or we don't know, I suppose, do we? I think they're afraid of the king. I mean, they're afraid of Marduk. They're afraid that they have kind of blasphemed, that by laying their hands on the god and removing him from his home. Yeah. And Marduk is just the god of Babylon.
然后他们偷偷把它运回去，或者带回去，或者我们不知道，我想是吧？我想他们是害怕国王。我的意思是，他们害怕马尔杜克。他们害怕自己犯了亵渎罪，因为他们把手伸向了神明并将其从他的家中移走。是的。而马尔杜克只是巴比伦的神。
He hasn't spread. Or has he spread? He's starting to. He's becoming more and more important. And he's one of a whole constellation of gods yes um so that there are lots of gods um but marduk is kind of gradually going up the league table so the longer babylon endures yeah the more prestigious it becomes uh the more of a kind of cultural heft it has so the more it seems obvious both to the babylonians but then also to people who are starting to think of
他还没有传播开来。或者说他传播了吗？他开始传播了。他变得越来越重要。他是众多神明中的一员，是的，嗯，所以有很多神明，嗯，但马尔杜克在排行榜上的地位逐渐上升，所以巴比伦存在的时间越长，是的，它就越有名望，嗯，它拥有的文化分量就越重，因此，不仅对巴比伦人来说，而且对于开始认为
themselves as belonging to a place called babylonia that marduk you know i mean he can't just be the god of babylon i mean he has to be king of the gods surely so it's a kind of gradual slow process of promotion right yes it's it's sort of the soft power yes absolutely yes uh and babylon is actually on the receiving end a lot at this point because then in 1176 bc i think so we're basically what 75 years later it is sacked again um this time by the evil terrible time so elam are you going to pronounce it elam or something no elam is good elam um where's where's elam so that's it that's um uh in iran so these are hordes of aliansaris descending right and they are much less respectful and they they inevitably nick the statue of
自己属于一个叫巴比伦尼亚的地方的人来说，马尔杜克，你知道的，我的意思是，他不能仅仅是巴比伦的神，我的意思是，他肯定必须是众神之王。所以这是一个循序渐进的缓慢晋升过程，对吧？是的，这有点像是软实力，是的，绝对是的，嗯，而且巴比伦在这个时候实际上经常处于受攻击的一端，因为在公元前1176年左右，我想，基本上也就是75年后，它再次被洗劫，嗯，这次是被邪恶可怕的埃兰人。埃兰，你们会把它读作埃兰还是别的什么？不，埃兰很好，埃兰，嗯，埃兰在哪里？那是在伊朗。所以这些是埃兰人的大军蜂拥而至，对吧，他们不那么恭敬，他们不可避免地偷走了
of course they do but they they also steal the famous law code of Hammurabi and they take it back to Susa, their capital. Yeah. And, you know, it's a great trophy. And that is where it gets then subsequently, much, much later, it gets found by French archaeologists who then take it to the Louvre. So there's these cycles of looting,
他们当然会这么做，但他们还偷走了著名的《汉谟拉比法典》，并将其带回他们的首都苏萨。是的。而且，你知道，这是一个巨大的战利品。后来，在很久很久以后，它被法国考古学家发现，然后被带到了卢浮宫。所以这里有掠夺的循环，
but also of kind of archaeological fascination with the past. So in that sense, the French who found it were truly the heirs of Babylon. So at that point, I mean, actually, it's interesting, isn't it? Because when the Elamites take the law code of Hammurabi, that is, I'm just working that out, they're 600, 700 years on from that.
但也有对过去的某种考古学迷恋。所以从这个意义上说，发现它的法国人确实是巴比伦的继承人。所以在那个时候，我的意思是，实际上这很有趣，不是吗？因为当埃兰人拿走《汉谟拉比法典》时，那是，我只是在计算，他们距离那个时期有600、700年了。
So, I mean, that to them is an artifact as old i mean even longer as a as a as a a medieval you know plantagenet thing would be to us i suppose like taking magna carta or something yeah it's yeah it's i mean they can't even read it presumably i think they probably can really well because it's the lingua franca but it's surely evolved in the intervening 700 years or whatever. No, because there's a kind of conscious antiquarianism. So if you have a Babylonian scribe, he'll be able to read it. So it's as though it were in Latin, basically.
所以，对他们来说，那是一件极其古老的文物，我的意思是，甚至比中世纪的普朗塔热内王朝的东西对我们来说还要古老，我想，就像拿走《大宪章》或类似的东西一样，是的，这，我的意思是，他们甚至可能都读不懂它。我想他们可能读得很好，因为那是通用语，但在随后的700年里它肯定已经演变了，或者诸如此类。不，因为有一种有意识的复古主义。所以如果你有一个巴比伦抄写员，他就能读懂它。所以它基本上就像是用拉丁语写的。
It's a kind of lingua franca and it has an antiquarian prestige? No, because it's not a completely different language. It's the same language. And so Babylonian kings are writing stuff in in way i you know it's like us using thee or thou or something in a you know in a document yeah um it's it's it's kind of got an antique feel but definitely you can read it now tom in the notes that you sent me because tom very kindly sent me a whole load of notes because he thought i was utterly incapable of informing myself about babbitt to be fair, you were actually right.
这是一种通用语，并且具有复古的威望？不，因为它不是一种完全不同的语言。它是同一种语言。所以巴比伦国王用……写东西，你知道，这就像我们在文件中使用‘thee’或‘thou’（古英语的你）一样，嗯，它有一种古旧的感觉，但你绝对可以读懂它。现在，汤姆，在你发给我的笔记里——因为汤姆非常友好地发给我整整一堆笔记，因为他认为我完全没有能力了解巴比伦——公平地说，你其实说得对。
It says in the notes, I don't know if this is you, I think it looks like you're quoting somebody, from now until the period of the Syrian supremacy in the 8th century BC, the country was ruled by six politically unimportant dynasters. I just thought that was very funny. So again, you were saying that 400 years ago. So the Elamites, when they sack Babylon, they also transport the last of the Kassite kings. So that's terminus for the elamites when they sack babylon they they also transport the last of the
笔记里写道，我不知道这是否是你，我觉得这看起来像你在引用别人的话：从现在到公元前8世纪亚述霸权时期，这个国家由六个政治上无足轻重的朝代统治。我只是觉得这非常有趣。所以，你又说那是400年前的事了。因此，埃兰人在洗劫巴比伦时，也运走了加喜特王朝最后的国王们。所以这是埃兰人洗劫巴比伦的终点……当他们洗劫巴比伦时，他们还运走了最后的
kings so that's terminus for the cassites yeah and so now suddenly you've got six politically unimportant dynasties that's that's like 400 500 years well it's not quite it's not quite because because actually about 50 years after the sack, you get the first guy to be called Nebuchadnezzar pops up on the scene. Is he Nebuchadnezzar or is he Nebuchadrezzar? Well, same difference. Okay, fair enough. He's only king for, what is he king for? 20 years? 21 years? Yeah, but he does quite a lot in that time because he wants to get marduk back right so so he he attacks elam and they get hit by the plague so that's not good so he has to withdraw and then he attacks again in high summer and everyone who followed the iraq war will know
国王，所以这是加喜特人的终点，是的。所以现在你突然有了六个政治上无足轻重的朝代，那大约是400、500年，嗯，也不完全是，因为实际上在洗劫发生大约50年后，第一个被称为尼布甲尼撒的人出现在了历史舞台上。他是尼布甲尼撒（Nebuchadnezzar）还是尼布甲雷查尔（Nebuchadrezzar）？好吧，都一样。好吧，有道理。他只当了国王，他当了多久国王？20年？21年？是的，但在那期间他做了相当多的事，因为他想把马尔杜克弄回来。所以，所以他进攻埃兰，结果他们遭遇了瘟疫，所以这可不好，他不得不撤退，然后在盛夏再次发动进攻，经历过伊拉克战争的人都会知道
how hot it gets and there's this incredible description from one of the cuneiform tablets where it describes how the axes in the soldier's hands burn like fire and the road surfaces scorch like flame you know so you real credible sense of of the heat but this is he's able to um surprise elamites he gets marduk back and this is really the point from which marduk is being enshrined as as top dog as and on the tablets tom i mean that description that you read out what is that is that a history is it a um what are they writing there's there's a lot of boasting that goes that goes on in ancient mesopotamia the guys who really really boast about um all their victories and stuff are the assyrians so So they're always going on about, we sacked this, I impaled this king,
天气有多热，楔形文字泥板上有这样一个令人难以置信的描述，它描述了士兵手中的斧头燃烧如火，道路表面灼热如火焰，你知道的，所以你对那种酷热有着非常真实真切的感官体验。但他能够出其不意地袭击埃兰人，他把马尔杜克带了回来，这确实是马尔杜克被奉为至高无上的神明的起点。而且在泥板上，汤姆，我的意思是，你读的那段描述，那是什么？那是历史吗？还是一个，他们在写什么？在古代美索不达米亚，有很多夸耀之词。那些真正极力夸耀自己所有胜利等等的人是亚述人。
I chopped off his head and hung it from a tree. I destroyed the city and transported all the people. A lot of boasting. You know, they do it not just in written form, but in, you know, freezes. So again, the British Museum, they have these incredible illustrations of the Assyrian army at work. Terrifying. Babylonians, Babylonian kings are generally keener
所以我总是喋喋不休地说，我们洗劫了这里，我把这个国王串在木桩上，我砍下他的头并将它挂在树上。我摧毁了城市并运走了所有人。有很多夸耀。你知道，他们不仅以文字形式这样做，还以浮雕形式这样做。所以同样，在大英博物馆，他们有这些令人难以置信的亚述军队行动的插图。太可怕了。巴比伦人，巴比伦国王通常更热衷于
on boasting about how many buildings they've put up. So that's what they really like to go on about. Yeah. But, you know, there's a bit of boasting about all the stuff that they've done as well. Well, they should be pleased with themselves. I mean, they've got their statue back. Yeah, absolutely.
夸耀他们建造了多少建筑物。所以这才是他们真正喜欢滔滔不绝谈论的。是的。但是，你知道，对他们所做过的一切事情也有一些吹嘘。好吧，他们应该为自己感到高兴。我的意思是，他们把神像夺回来了。是的，绝对的。
And presumably to them, not having the statue means that they're in some way mutilated, ideologically mutilated. They need the statue because Marduk is the god and, you know, without him, they can't be whole. So they've got him back. But they don't then go on to, you know, to dominate the region, do they? Because then the Assyrians are the big men again. Is that right? Or the Assyrians maybe have been the big power all through this time.
而且对他们来说，没有神像可能意味着他们在某种程度上被阉割了，在意识形态上被阉割了。他们需要神像，因为马尔杜克是神，你知道，没有他，他们就不完整。所以他们把神像夺回来了。但他们并没有接着去统治这个地区，对吧？因为接下来亚述人再次成为了大佬。是这样吗？还是说亚述人其实一直都是这段时期的超级大国？
Well, they've gone kind of into eclipse and now they've come back again. And this is the period that everyone who's familiar with the Bible will know where they're just kind of like the wolf on the fold. They're terrifying and you don't want to mess with them. The advantage that Babylon has is that the Assyrians respect Babylon. They see it as the cultural capital of the world. So there's a lot of respect. But then the Babylonians make the mistake of launching a full-scale revolt. And they ally themselves
好吧，他们曾经黯然失色，现在又卷土重来。这段时期凡是熟悉《圣经》的人都会知道，他们就像是羊圈里的狼。他们太可怕了，你绝对不想惹他们。巴比伦的优势在于亚述人尊重巴比伦。他们视其为世界的文化之都。所以有很大的尊重。但随后巴比伦人犯了一个错误，发动了全面起义。他们与
with the Elamites, who have now become their friends. Right. So they've forgiven the Elamites for the previous theft of Marduk. Yeah. And they're facing the Assyrian army, the most frightening in the world. And the king of Elam gets locked jaw.
埃兰人结盟，而埃兰人现在已经成为了他们的朋友。对。所以他们原谅了埃兰人先前对马尔杜克神像的盗窃。是的。他们面对的是世界上最可怕的亚述军队。而埃兰国王却得了牙关紧闭症。
Gosh. He can't shut his mouth well it's hard to shout out orders right also engage in complicated tactical discussions yeah it's the last thing you want when the assyrians so i changed the second and his nosebleed during the glorious revolution yeah so so he doesn't come because he's kind of ah so that's my favorite of all your impersonations is the yeah so so he's ah and so the babylonians are left to face the assyrians on their own and they've got they've got obviously got massive walls so they're able to hold out and they last for 15 months and then the city falls you know and have you got an exciting description of the fall of the city
天哪。他张不开嘴了。嗯，这很难大声发布命令，对吧？也很难参与复杂的战术讨论。是的，当亚述人……这是你最不想遇到的事，所以辛那赫里布在光荣革命期间流鼻血了，对吧？所以他没有来，因为他有点“啊”。所以在我对你所有的模仿中，我最喜欢的就是这个“啊”。所以他“啊”，于是巴比伦人只好独自面对亚述人。他们显然拥有巨大的城墙，所以他们能够坚守，他们坚持了15个月，然后城市陷落了，你知道，你有没有对城市陷落的精彩描述？
i have so this is the syrian king seneca rib so seneca rib um and this is this is kind of classic assyrian boasting this is the kind of stuff that syrian kings went in for i destroyed the city and its houses from foundation to parapet i devastated and burned them i raised the brick and earth and work of the outer and inner wall of the city, of the temples, of the ziggurat. I dumped these into the canal. I dug canals through the midst of that city. I overwhelmed it with water. I made its very foundations disappear, and I destroyed it more completely than a devastating flood, so that it might be impossible in future days to recognize the site of that city and its temples i utterly dissolved it with water and made it like
有的。所以这是亚述国王辛那赫里布。所以辛那赫里布，这是典型的亚述式吹嘘，这是亚述国王们惯用的伎俩：我摧毁了这座城市及其房屋，从地基到胸墙。我将其毁灭并付之一炬。我把城市内外墙、神庙和高塔的砖石和泥土铲起，把这些倾倒进运河。我在那座城市中央开凿运河。我用水淹没了它。我让它的地基彻底消失，我摧毁它比毁灭性的洪水还要彻底，以至于在未来日子里不可能认出那座城市及其神庙的遗址。我用水彻底溶化了它，使它变成了
inundated land so that dominic is the answer to your question about why we we have no real idea about what the city of hara rabbi was like senna carib is not a sentimental man i would guess no and inevitably he steals something does he take the uh statue of marduk by any chance he does he does he does and what's he when they take the statue what do they do with it they take it back in great honor and again this is this is important um they senecrub goes back to assyria he says i've destroyed babylon so now babylon is in assyria so i think he takes the statue of marduk to assa or nineveh i can't remember which one but one of the great cities of Assyria. And he says, this is, actually, I think it's Nineveh. And he says, Nineveh is now Babylon.
一片被水淹没的土地。所以，多米尼克，这就是对你那个问题的回答：为什么我们对汉谟拉比时期的城市没有真正的概念？我猜辛那赫里布可不是个多愁善感的人。不。而且不可避免地，他偷了点东西。难道他顺便拿走了马尔杜克的雕像吗？他拿了，他拿了，他拿了。当他们拿走雕像时，他们用它做什么？他们怀着极大的敬意把它带了回去，同样，这也是很重要的。辛那赫里布回到亚述，他说：我已经摧毁了巴比伦，所以现在巴比伦在亚述。所以我想他把马尔杜克的雕像带到了亚述或尼尼微，我不记得是哪一个了，但那是亚述的伟大城市之一。他说，实际上，我想是尼尼微。他说，尼尼微现在就是巴比伦。
So it basically laid claim to their historical legacy and their garden. Absolutely. So Marduk gets enshrined in Nineveh. And basically, it's kind of new Babylon. And he's laying claim to, you know, all the inheritance of Babylon. However, the Assyrians clearly, again, feel bad about this. They feel nervous about it. And his son, Esarhaddon, who has a Babylonian wife, he restores the statue of Marduk and he starts kind of sponsoring the rebuilding of it.
所以他基本上宣称拥有了他们的历史遗产和他们的花园。绝对的。所以马尔杜克被供奉在尼尼微。基本上，这就是新巴比伦。他宣称拥有巴比伦的一切遗产。然而，亚述人显然又为此感到内疚。他们对此感到不安。他的儿子阿萨尔哈东（Esarhaddon）娶了一位巴比伦妻子，他修复了马尔杜克的雕像，并开始资助其重建。
And he has two sons, one of them, a guy called Shamash Shuma Ukin, crazy name, crazy guy, who becomes the king of Babylon. And then he has a younger son, but who is not the son of a Babylonian wife, so so therefore syrian through and through he was called asha banapal so he does that does he do that crazy thing that people do in dividing his kingdom in two between two sons and hoping that somehow it'll be all right kind of i i think that that um asha banapal is clearly number one king right um and uh but but but shamashuma iskin is number two. Yeah, and he's the elder brother,
他有两个儿子，其中一个是叫沙马什·舒马·乌金（Shamash Shuma Ukin）的人，名字很疯狂，人也很疯狂，他成为了巴比伦的国王。然后他还有一个小儿子，但不是巴比伦妻子所生，所以从头到尾都是亚述血统，他叫亚述巴尼拔（Ashurbanipal）。所以他做了那件事吗？人们常做的那种把王国一分为二给两个儿子，并希望某种程度上一切都会好起来的疯狂事？差不多吧，我想阿萨尔哈东，哦不，亚述巴尼拔显然是头号国王，对吧？而且，但但但沙马什·舒马·乌金是二号。是的，他是哥哥，
so I think he's a bit cross about that. So there are tensions there. Yeah, so the idea is that it's going to be a kind of double monarchy, but as you say, I mean, these things never work out. So Babylon is being rebuilt. Marduk has been returned to the esagila um the the lake has been drained they're starting to rebuild um the the great central ziggurat and this basically is
所以我猜他对此有点生气。所以这其中存在紧张关系。是的，所以这个想法是建立一个双头君主国，但正如你所说，我的意思是，这些事情从来都不会成功。所以巴比伦正在重建。马尔杜克被送回了埃萨吉拉神庙，湖水被排干了，他们开始重建宏伟的中央高塔，这基本上就是
the model for the tower of babylon so it's our process of yeah yeah sorry the tower of babel so this is the process of rebuilding it it doesn't work because in 652, the two brothers go to war. And this is obviously a terrible decision on the part of Shammashuma Ukin because his brother basically has his Syrian war machine at his command. And so inevitably Babylon gets captured. And Shammashuma Ukin's palace gets put on fire and he supposedly hurls himself into the flames. And this gets remembered by fire and he supposedly hurls himself into the flames and this gets remembered
巴别塔的原型。所以这是……的过程，是的，抱歉，巴别塔。所以这是重建它的过程。这并没有奏效，因为在公元52年，两个兄弟爆发了战争。这对于沙马什·舒马·乌金来说显然是一个可怕的决定，因为他的兄弟基本上可以调动他的亚述战争机器。所以巴比伦不可避免地被攻陷了。沙马什·舒马·乌金的宫殿被付之一炬，据传说他把自己投进了烈火中。这被……铭记，他把自己投进了烈火中，这被
by uh by greek and roman writers who call him sardanapalus um and sardanapalus becomes this he's remembered as this guy who uh he he he's very transgender uh he likes to kind of hang out with his concubines he doesn't can't be bothered with, you know, with, with fighting. And at the end, he kind of hurls himself into the flames. Byron writes a play about him.
希腊和罗马作家所铭记，他们称他为萨达纳帕卢斯（Sardanapalus）。萨达纳帕卢斯成了这样一个人，他被人们记住是一个……他非常雌雄同体，他喜欢和他的妃嫔们厮混，他才懒得去理会什么打仗。最后，他把自己投进了烈火中。拜伦还为他写过一部剧作。
So that's Shamash done. He's over. Ashurbanipal. Is he, is he in a mood to be merciful? No, I'm reading it now. I fed it.
所以沙马什就这样完了。他结束了。亚述巴尼拔。他，他现在心情好想大发慈悲吗？不，我正在读这段文字。我喂了他们。
I fed their corpses cut into small pieces to dogs, pigs, vultures, the birds of the sky and the fish of the ocean. He's not messing about, is he? No. And do you know what? He's the intellectual one. So he's got his library. He's the philosopher king.
我把切成小块的他们的尸体喂给狗、猪、秃鹫、天空中的飞鸟和海洋里的鱼。他可真不是闹着玩的，对吧？没有。而且你知道吗？他是个有文化的人。所以他有他的图书馆。他是哲学家国王。
He's the philosopher king. And he's chopping his enemies up into little bits and feeding them to dogs and vultures. But that just might be a figure of speech, Tom. Mightn you don't think so you think he's fed them to fish that's what he's claiming yes i i think so okay well tom that's been a brilliant insight into the world of babylon before nebuchadnezzar and again if you haven't listened to our episode on nebuchadnezzar's babylon it was in january and what can they expect to hear in it, Tom? Yes. So that episode, basically, it goes from when Ashurbanipal, the last great Assyrian king,
他是哲学家国王。而他却把他的敌人切成小碎块喂给狗和秃鹫。但这可能只是一种修辞手法，汤姆。你不这么认为吗？你觉得他是把他们喂给鱼了，这就是他所宣称的。是的，我想是的。好吧，汤姆，这真是对尼布甲尼撒之前巴比伦世界的极好见解。再次强调，如果你还没有听过我们关于尼布甲尼撒的巴比伦的那期节目，那是在一月份发布的。他们在节目中可以期待听到什么呢，汤姆？是的。所以那一集，基本上，是从亚述巴尼拔——最后一个伟大的亚述国王——
dies. Assyria implodes. And one of the victorious powers that dismembers the Assyrian empire is this revived Babylonian empire. So that's the empire of Nebuchadnezzar, the empire that everyone kind of sees in their mind's eye when they think of Babylon, the Ishtar Gate and all that kind of stuff. And he is the king who sacks Jerusalem. He's the king who is basically presiding over the Tower of Babel that then gets kind of appears in the book of Genesis and supposedly builds the Hanging Gardens. Although whether he does or not, you will find out in that episode. So if you haven't heard it, it is episode number 145 in the Restless History podcast feed. And if you have heard it, very good. And thanks for coming back for another bite of Babylon. So it's goodbye from me and it's goodbye from him. Bye-bye.
死去开始的。亚述土崩瓦解。肢解亚述帝国的胜利势力之一就是这个复兴的巴比伦帝国。这就是尼布甲尼撒的帝国，也就是每个人在脑海中想到巴比伦时想象的那个帝国，伊什塔尔城门以及诸如此类的东西。他是洗劫耶路撒冷的国王。他是 presiding over（统领）巴别塔的国王，这座塔后来出现在了《创世记》中，并且据说建造了空中花园。至于他到底有没有建造，你将在那一集中找到答案。所以如果你还没听过，那是《The Rest Is History》播客源中的第145集。如果你已经听过了，那很好。感谢你再次回来品味巴比伦。我是主持人，他是主持人，我们说再见。拜拜。
Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. That have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听《The Rest Is History》。如需收听独家节目、提前解锁、无广告畅听以及访问我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告畅听、独家节目以及提前购买现场门票的权限，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。